A big thank you to squarespace for
sponsoring this video.
It's not easy butchering people's hard
work physically and mentally.
I don't think people realize you need to
vent.
One of the more fascinating aspects of
David fincher's mind hunter is that it
is not just a detective thriller.
Dad Explores the psychology of serial
killers but at it also explores why we
are so fascinated by them,
why we are drawn to the dark,
why we are captivated,
haunted and teased by the unthinkable.
Although collecting serial killer
memorabilia or writing them letters is a
fringe activity.
Serial killers in habits of prominence
position within both our nonfictional
and fictional popular culture,
people are glued to coverage of real
life serial killers such as Ted Bundy,
Eileen wound,
and Jeffrey Dahmer who all have their
own documentaries and films.
I now present to you Jeffrey Dahmer in
his command performance.
These real killers together with popular
fictional depictions of serial killers
such as Hannibal Lecter or dexter and
John Doe demonstrate how eager the
public is to learn more about him.
The way in which mind center treats and
thesises with accurate representations
of real life.
Serial killers was described by review
as serial killer fence surface.
Serial killers are this feud in our
culture,
both as despicable monsters,
monster,
right?
I think we can all agree
and fascinating cool celebrities.
You would really turn down the chance to
meet Richard Speck is almost up there.
They're advancing.
Or maybe he'll give you an autograph,
but why is this?
Why can't we get enough of them?
The first episode of tend to suggest
that there is a connection between the
behavior of these killers and the
broader state of culture and society,
democracy,
Spanish style.
What are
just a response to turmoil?
The government used to be symbolically a
parental institution.
It's a free for all.
The world barely makes any sense.
So it follows the crime doesn't either.
Is that what we see in serial killers?
Are they an extreme representation of
our broader society for which we are all
responsible?
Of course,
holden and bill soon find out that
serial killers are not crazy rampant
aberrational parallels to the crazy
chaotic culture of the sixties and
seventies
that's that friends eat.
I don't know what the hell is
meticulous,
highly intelligent.
The scholars can be intelligent and
organized with very clear motivations
for their quote unquote work such as
sex,
power and domination.
I'm just saying people who hunt other
people for a vocation,
all we want to talk about is what it's
like
this.
If serial killers are an extreme
representation of human culture,
they are so in the way.
Historian Carsten Fisher describes,
he argues that serial killers often
developed in the same way as human
civilizations,
do civilizations in their fields,
the unknown,
half need to organize,
control and dominate nature and other
people.
Therefore first domesticating and
killing animals and so later in
sloughing and it's killing all the
humans.
Just a serial killer,
start with torturing and killing animals
before they move on to people.
So then it became dogs and cats
strangling them,
burying them in the backyard.
Hold on.
Sorry.
On an individual level.
This theory is also reflected by
[inaudible] concept of the shadow self.
You argue stairs.
We repress primitive,
negative socially or religiously
depreciate as human emotions and
impulses like sexual loss,
power striving,
selfishness,
creeds and anger or rage into our own
consciousness.
Our dark side,
so to speak,
the shadow self is to counterpoint to
what you called a persona,
which is our conscious ego.
How we see ourselves and represent
ourselves to watch the worlds.
That's by Erving Goffman.
He posits that life was like theater.
We tailor ourselves to fit the parts
that were playing in a social
interaction.
Awesome.
Yeah.
To put performance,
there's an onstage area where
individuals are actress as the case may
be appear before the origins,
but I must be backstage hidden private
area where individuals can truly be
themselves.
Of course,
emily,
I argued that it's mine.
Tinter explosive notion that this is why
we are fascinated by serial killers
because we seen them extreme versions of
personality traits that are part of us,
but as we repress into our own
consciousness that are part of our
shadow selves,
the series primary Dastis to the
character of Holden Ford.
In the early episodes we primarily see
Holden's persona.
He seems smart,
that humble,
idealistic with a real drive to do
goods.
You sure you want me doing that?
You're smart,
you're idealistic,
more than a little sensitive,
they're going to love you.
However,
he already mentioned Sitek that he will
later use in his interviews with serial
killers,
try understanding him instead of trying
to dominate,
look for common ground,
find calming down.
Because of this very slowly over the
course of the season,
due to his extensive interactions with
these killers,
personality traits off his shadow self
come forwards,
traits such as envy and fucked up views
of sex and women,
which he claims is just an interview
technique,
but it seems fairly much connectors to
the state of this relationship.
What gave you the right to take eight
right consent of the world?
Some of them looked pretty good.
You would think you were depriving the
rest of us
while also becoming more arrogant and
power hungry.
You think,
I don't know what you're doing with this
principal's office bullshit.
This is what I do with violent
offenders.
Only much better.
Two CDs in contrast in episode three he
is celebrating a successful case like
this.
Thank you for acknowledging what my
partner bill and I are doing
and for embracing that.
If we all work together,
we can venture into the blackest night
and shine a light on the darkness.
Well,
an episode 10 it is a different story.
I don't think I'm speaking at an
attorney or when I say I.
However,
I have heard some people suggest as
holden in the next season might become a
serial killer himself.
I think this would be too easily a plot
twist after such a slow and subtle
transformation into a shadow self.
More importantly,
the concept of the shadow self doesn't
mean we are all secretly murderous
psychopath.
Serial killers represent extreme
versions of negative traits that normal
people would possess in a much more
minor capacity call.
You argue stair to become once complete
self.
The shadow self needs to be recognized,
acknowledged and accepted as Jordan
Peterson argues this can be done to an
intellectual exercise when you
contemplate your own capacity for evil
and I don't think,
and this is something I did learn from
yoga is that you cannot be a good person
until you know how much evil you contain
within you.
It is not possible and it's a very
strange thing because you wouldn't think
that the revelation of the capacity for
evil is a precondition for the
realization of good but I believe at
first of all why would you be serious
enough to even attempt to pursue the
good unless you had some sense of what
the consequence was of not doing it with
you
guards to hold him.
He doesn't seem aware of his own shadow
self coming forwards until possibly the
very ends of the season.
In my opinion,
it is unclear whilst holding force
breakdown signifies two two s clash with
Kemper.
He might've become aware of its own
shadow self coming forwards,
becoming a more balanced person and the
next season,
who am I going to fuck him?
Fuck police torture mutilation.
This made you paranoid.
It could also mean that he will spin
fruit out of control.
Is Shadow self taking over a while being
unable to catch a new serial killer on
the rice.
My in Toronto.
We will continue to explore this
psychology of serial killers profiling
some of the world's most famous ones,
but it's me.
Yeah.
B It is simultaneously profiling us.
Well.
All right.
Thank you for watching and thank you to
squarespace for sponsoring this video.
You probably have seen a feature in
other videos before,
but it's rightfully so.
As someone who doesn't know how to code,
I've worked with several website
templates systems in the past and
squarespace is by far the most elegant
and easiest to use.
You also don't have to pay for any
subscription or a website domain upfront
using the free trial.
You can design your complete website
before deciding to pay for anything.
So if you want to feature your serial
killer memorabilia or maybe just your
music videos or artwork on the website,
you,
squarespace.com/storytellers and also
get 10% off your first purchase.
The link is in the description below.
Now,
if you want to support our channel and
get some stickers,
you can do some patron or sensitive to
paypal.
And lastly,
I want to give a shout out to fellow
video essay,
John from before the credits for helping
me out with some of the practicalities
of this video.
Check them out to link is also in the
description below.
All right guys,
thank you for watching and film.
This video will be up next Saturday,
so look out for that.
See you next time.
Yeah.